[Music]
hello and welcome to the docker for
beginners course my name is mumsha
bonambat and i will be your instructor
for this course
i'm a devops and cloud trainer at
codecloud.com which is an interactive
hands-on online learning platform
i've been working in the industry as a
consultant for over 13 years and have
helped hundreds of thousands of students
learn technology in a fun and
interactive way in this course you will
learn docker through a series of
lectures that use animation illustration
and some fun analogies
that simplify complex concepts we have
demos that will show you how to install
and get started with docker and most
importantly we have hands-on labs that
you can access right in your browser i
will explain more about it in a bit but
first let's look at the objectives of
this course
in this course we first try to
understand what containers are what
docker is and why you might need it and
what it can do for you we will see how
to run a docker container how to build
your own docker image we will see
networking in docker and how to use
docker compose what locker registry is
how to deploy your own private registry
and we then look at some of these
concepts in depth and we try to
understand how docker really works under
the hoods
we look at docker for windows and mac
before finally getting a basic
introduction to container orchestration
tools
like docker swamp and kubernetes here's
a quick note about hands-on labs first
of all to complete this course you don't
have to set up your own labs well you
may set it up if you wish to
if you wish to have your own environment
and we have a demo as well but as part
of this course we provide real labs that
you can access right in your browser
anywhere anytime and as many times as
you want the labs give you instant
access to a terminal to a docker host
and an accompanying quiz portal the quiz
portal asks a set of questions such as
exploring the environment and gathering
information or you might be asked to
perform an action such as run docker
container the quiz portal then validates
your work and gives you feedback
instantly every lecture in this course
is accompanied by such challenging
interactive quizzes that makes learning
docker a fun activity so i hope you're
as thrilled as i am to get started so
let us begin
[Music]
we're going to start by looking at a
high level overview on why you need
docker and what it can do for you let me
start by sharing how i got introduced to
docker in one of my previous projects i
had this requirement to set up an
end-to-end application stack including
various different technologies like a
web server using node.js and a database
such as mongodb and a messaging system
like redis and an orchestration tool
like ansible we had a lot of issues
developing this application stack with
all these different components
first of all their compatibility with
the underlying os was an issue we had to
ensure that all these different services
were compatible with the version of os
we were planning to use there have been
times when certain version of these
services were not compatible with the os
and we've had to go back and look at
different os that was compatible with
all of these different services
secondly we had to check the
compatibility between these services and
the libraries and dependencies on the os
we've had issues where one service
requires one version of a dependent
library whereas another service requires
another version
the architecture of our application
changed over time we've had to upgrade
to newer versions of these components or
change the database etc and every time
something changed we had to go through
the same process of checking
compatibility between these various
components
and the underlying infrastructure
this compatibility matrix issue is
usually referred to as the matrix from
hell
next every time we had a new developer
on board we found it really difficult to
set up a new environment the new
developers had to follow a large set of
instructions and run hundreds of
commands to finally set up their
environment we had to make sure they
were using the right operating system
the right versions of each of these
components and each developer had to set
all that up by himself each time
we also had different development tests
and production environments
one developer may be convertible using
one os and the others may be comfortable
using another one and so we couldn't
guarantee that the application that we
were building would run the same way in
different environments and so all of
this made our life in developing
building and shipping the application
really difficult
so i needed something that could help us
with the compatibility issue and
something that will allow us to modify
or change these components without
affecting the other components and even
modify the underlying operating systems
as required
and that search landed me on docker
with docker i was able to run each
component in a separate container with
its own dependencies and its own
libraries
all on the same vm and the os but within
separate environments or containers
we just had to build the docker
configuration once and all our
developers could now get started with a
simple docker run command irrespective
of what the underlying operating system
there on all they needed to do was to
make sure they had docker installed on
their systems
so what are containers containers are
completely isolated environments as in
they can have their own processes or
services their own network interfaces
their own mounts just like virtual
machines except they all share the same
os kernel
we will look at what that means in a bit
but it's also important to note that
containers are not new with docker
containers have existed for about 10
years now and some of the different
types of containers are lxc lxd lx cfs
etc
docker utilizes lxc containers setting
up these container environments is hard
as they are very low level and that is
where docker offers a high level tool
with several powerful functionalities
making it really easy for end users like
us
to understand how docker works let us
revisit some basic concepts of operating
systems first
if you look at operating systems like
ubuntu fedora suse or centos they all
consist of two things an os kernel and a
set of software
the os kernel is responsible for
interacting with the underlying hardware
while the os kernel remains the same
which is linux in this case it's the
software above it that makes these
operating systems different
this software may consist of a different
user interface drivers compilers file
managers developer tools etc
so you have a common linux kernel shared
across all oss and some custom software
that differentiate operating systems
from each other
we said earlier that docker containers
share the underlying kernel so what does
that actually mean sharing the kernel
let's say we have a system with an
ubuntu os with docker installed on it
docker can run any flavor of os on top
of it as long as they are all based on
the same kernel in this case linux
if the underlying os is ubuntu docker
can run a container based on another
distribution like debian fedora suse or
centos
each docker container only has the
additional software that we just talked
about in the previous slide that makes
these operating systems different and
docker utilizes the underlying kernel of
the docker host which works with all oss
above
so what is an os that do not share the
same kernel as this
windows and so you won't be able to run
a windows based container on a docker
host with linux on it for that you will
require a docker on a windows server
now it is when i say this that most of
my students go hey hold on there that's
not true and they install docker on
windows run a container based on linux
and go see it's possible
well when you install docker on windows
and run a linux container on windows
you're not really running a linux
container on windows windows runs a
linux container on a linux virtual
machine under the hoods so it's really
linux container on linux virtual machine
on windows we discuss more about this
on the docker on windows or
mac later during this course
now you might ask isn't that a
disadvantage then not being able to run
another kernel on the os
the answer is no because unlike
hypervisors docker is not meant to
virtualize and run different operating
systems and kernels on the same hardware
the main purpose of docker is to package
and containerize applications and to
ship them and to run them anywhere
anytime
as many times as you want
so that brings us to the differences
between virtual machines and containers
something that we tend to do especially
those from a virtualization background
as you can see on the right in case of
docker we have the underlying hardware
infrastructure and then the os and then
docker installed on the os docker then
manages the containers that run with
libraries and dependencies alone
in case of virtual machines we have the
hypervisor like esx on the hardware and
then the virtual machines on them as you
can see each virtual machine has its own
os inside it then the dependencies and
then the application
the overhead causes higher utilization
of underlying resources as there are
multiple virtual operating systems and
kernels running
the virtual machines also consume higher
disk space as each vm is heavy and is
usually in gigabytes in size whereas
docker containers are light feed and are
usually in megabytes in size
this allows docker containers to boot up
faster usually in a matter of seconds
whereas vms as we know takes minutes to
boot up as it needs to boot up the
entire operating system
it is also important to note that docker
has less isolation as more resources are
shared between the containers like the
kernel whereas vms have complete
isolation from each other
since vms don't rely on the underlying
os or kernel you can run different types
of applications built on different oss
such as linux based or windows based
apps on the same hypervisor
so those are some differences between
the two now having said that it's not an
either container or virtual machine
situation
it's containers and virtual machines now
when you have large environments with
thousands of application containers
running on thousands of docker hosts you
will often see containers provisioned on
virtual docker hosts
that way we can utilize the advantages
of both technologies we can use the
benefits of virtualization to easily
provision or decommission docker hosts
as required at the same time make use of
the benefits of docker to easily
provision applications and quickly scale
them as required
but remember that in this case we will
not be provisioning that many virtual
machines as we used to before because
earlier we provisioned a virtual machine
for each application now you might
provision a virtual machine for hundreds
or thousands of containers
so how is it done there are lots of
containerized versions of applications
readily available as of today so most
organizations have their products
containerized and available in a public
docker repository called docker hub or
docker store
for example you can find images of most
common operating systems databases and
other services and tools
once you identify the images you need
and you install docker on your host
bringing up an application
is as easy as running a docker run
command with the name of the image in
this case running a docker run ansible
command will run an instance of ansible
on the docker host similarly run an
instance of mongodb redis and node.js
using the docker run command
if we need to run multiple instances of
the web service simply add as many
instances as you need and configure a
load balancer of some kind in the front
in case one of the instances were to
fail simply destroy that instance and
launch a new one
there are other solutions available for
handling such cases that we will look at
later during this course
and for now don't focus too much on the
commands we will get to that in a bit
we've been talking about images and
containers let's understand the
difference between the two
an image is a package or a template just
like a vm template that you might have
worked with in the virtualization world
it is used to create one or more
containers
containers are running instances of
images that are isolated and have their
own environments and set of processes
as we have seen before a lot of products
have been dockerized already in case you
cannot find what you're looking for you
could create your own image and push it
to docker hub repository making it
available for public
so if you look at it
traditionally developers developed
applications then they hand it over to
ops team to deploy and manage it in
production environments
they do that by providing a set of
instructions such as information about
how the host must be set up what
prerequisites are to be installed on the
host and how the dependencies are to be
configured etc
since the ops team did not really
develop the application on their own
they struggle with setting it up when
they hit an issue they work with the
developers to resolve it with docker the
developers and operations teams work
hand in hand to transform the guide into
a docker file with both of their
requirements this docker file is then
used to create an image for their
applications
this image can now run on any host with
docker installed on it and is guaranteed
to run the same way everywhere so the
ops team can now simply use the image to
deploy the application since the image
was already working when the developer
built it and operations
are have not modified it it continues to
work the same way when deployed in
production
and that's one example of how a tool
like docker contributes to the devops
culture
well that's it for now and in the
upcoming lecture we will look at how to
get started with docker
[Music]
we will now see how to get started with
docker now docker has two editions the
community edition and the enterprise
edition
the community edition is the set of free
docker products the enterprise edition
is the certified and supported container
platform that comes with enterprise
add-ons like the image management image
security
universal control plane for managing an
orchestrating container runtimes but of
course these come with a price
we will discuss more about container
orchestration later in this course and
along with some alternatives
for now we will go ahead with the
community edition
the community edition is available on
linux mac windows or on cloud platforms
like aws or azure
in the upcoming demo we will take a look
at how to install and get started with
docker on a linux system
now if you are on mac or windows you
have two options either install a linux
vm using virtualbox or some kind of
virtualization platform
and then follow along with the upcoming
demo which is really the most easiest
way to get started with docker
the second option is to install docker
desktop for mac or docker desktop for
windows which are native applications
so if that is really what you want
check out the docker for mac and the
windows
sections towards the end of this course
and then head back here once you're all
set up
we will now head over to a demo and we
will take a look at how to install
docker on a linux machine
[Music]
in this demo we look at how to install
and get started with docker
first of all identify a system physical
or virtual machine or laptop that has a
supported operating system
in my case i have an ubuntu vm
go to docs.docker.com
and click on get docker
you will be taken to the docker engine
community edition page
that is the free version that we are
after
from the left hand menu select your
system type
i choose
linux in my case and then select your os
flavor i choose ubuntu
read through the prerequisites and
requirements
your ubuntu system must be 64-bit and
one of the supported versions like disco
cosmic bionic or cenial
in my case i have a bionic version
to confirm view the etsy release file
next
uninstall any older version
if one exists
so let's just make sure that there's
none on my host so i'll just copy and
paste that command
and i confirm that there are no older
version that exists on my system
the next step is to set up repository
and install the software
now there are two ways to go about this
the first is using the package manager
by first updating the repository using
the apt-get update command then
installing the prerequisite packages and
then adding docker's official gpg keys
and then installing docker
but i'm not going to go that route
there is an easier way
if you scroll all the way to the bottom
you will find the instructions to
install docker using the convenience
script
it's a script that automates the entire
installation process and works on most
operating systems
run the first command to download a copy
of the script and then run the second
command to execute the script to install
docker automatically give it a few
minutes to complete the installation
the installation is now successful
let us now check the version of docker
using the docker version command
we've installed version 19.03.1
we will now run a simple container to
ensure everything is working as expected
for this
head over to docker hub at
hub.docker.com
here you will find a list of the most
popular docker images like nginx mongodb
alpine node.js redis etc let's search
for a fun image called will say
we'll say is docker's version of cause
which is basically a simple application
that prints a cow
saying something
in this case it happens to be a whale
copy the docker run command given here
remember to add
sudo and we will change the message to
hello world
on running this command docker pulls the
image of the whalesa application from
docker hub
and runs it
and we have our veil
saying hello
great
we're all set
remember for the purpose of this course
you don't really need to set up a docker
system on your own
we provide hands-on labs that you will
get access to but
if you wish to experiment on your own
and follow along feel free to do so
we now look at some of the docker
commands at the end of this lecture you
will go through a hands-on quiz where
you will practice working with these
commands
let's start by looking at docker run
command
the docker run command is used to run a
container from an image running the
docker run nginx command will run an
instance of the nginx application on the
docker host if it already exists
if the image is not present on the host
it will go out to docker hub and pull
the image down
but this is only done the first time for
the subsequent executions the same image
will be reused
the docker ps command lists all running
containers and some basic information
about them such as the container id the
name of the image we used to run the
containers the current status and the
name of the container
each container automatically gets a
random id and name created for it by
docker which in this case is silly
summit
to see all containers running or not use
the dash a option this outputs all
running as well as previously stopped or
exited containers
we'll talk about the command and port
fields shown in this output later in
this course for now let's just focus on
the basic commands
to stop a running container use the
docker stop command but you must provide
either the container id or the container
name in the stop command
if you're not sure of the name run the
docker ps command to get it
on success you will see the name printed
out and running docker ps again will
show no running containers
running docker ps dash a however shows
the container silly summit and that it
is in an exited states
a few seconds ago
now what if we don't want this container
lying around consuming space what if we
want to get rid of it for good
use the docker rm command to remove a
stopped or exited container permanently
if it prints the name back we're good
run the docker ps command again to
verify that it's no longer present
good but what about the nginx image that
was downloaded at first we're not using
that anymore so how do we get rid of
that image
but first how do we see a list of images
present on our host
run the docker images command to see a
list of available images and their sizes
on our host we have four images nginx
redis ubuntu and alpine we will talk
about tags later in this course when we
discuss about
images
to remove an image that you no longer
plan to use run the docker rmi command
remember you must ensure that no
containers are running off of that image
before attempting to remove the image
you must stop and delete all dependent
containers to be able to delete an image
when we ran the docker run command
earlier it downloaded the ubuntu image
as it couldn't find one locally
what if we simply want to download the
image and keep so when we run the run
docker run command we don't want to wait
for it to download
use the docker pull command to only pull
the image and not run the container so
in this case the docker pull ubuntu
command pulls the ubuntu image and
stores it on our host
let's look at another example say you
were to run a docker container from an
ubuntu image when you run the docker run
ubuntu command it runs an instance of
ubuntu image and exits immediately
if you were to list the running
containers you wouldn't see the
container running if you list all
containers including those that are
stopped you will see that the new
container you ran is in an exited state
now why is that
unlike virtual machines containers are
not meant to host an operating system
containers are meant to run a specific
task or process such as to host an
instance of a web server or application
server or a database or simply to carry
some kind of computation or analysis
task
once the task is complete the container
exits a container only lives as long as
the process inside it is alive if the
web service inside the container is
stopped or crashed then the container
exits
this is why when you run a container
from an ubuntu image it stops
immediately because ubuntu is just an
image of an operating system that is
used as the base image for other
applications there is no process or
application running in it by default
if the image isn't running any service
as is the case with ubuntu you could
instruct docker to run a process with
the docker run command for example a
sleep command with a duration of 5
seconds
when the container starts it runs the
sleep command and goes into sleep for 5
seconds post which the sleep command
exits and the container stops
what we just saw was executing a command
when we run the container but what if we
would like to execute a command on a
running container for example when i run
the docker ps command i can see that
there is a running container which uses
the ubuntu image and sleeps for 100
seconds
let's say i would like to see the
contents of a file inside this
particular container i could use the
docker exec command to execute a command
on my docker container in this case to
print the contents of the etsy hosts
file
finally let's look at one more option
before we head over to the practice
exercises
i'm now going to run a docker image i
developed for a simple web application
the repository name is code cloud slash
simple web app
it runs a simple web server that listens
on port 8080
when you run a docker run command like
this
it runs in the foreground or in an
attached mode meaning you will be
attached to the console or the standard
out of the docker container and you will
see the output of the web service on
your screen
you won't be able to do anything else on
this console other than view the output
until this docker container stops
it won't respond to your inputs
press the control plus c combination to
stop the container and the application
hosted on the container exits and you
get back to your prompt
another option is to run the docker
container in the detached mode by
providing the dash d option
this will run the docker container in
the background mode and you will be back
to your prompt immediately the container
will continue to run in the backend
run the docker ps command to view the
running container
now if you would like to attach back to
the running container later
run the docker attach command and
specify the name or id of the docker
container
now remember
if you are specifying the id of a
container in any docker command you can
simply provide the first few characters
alone
just so it is different from the other
container ids on the host
in this case i specify
a043d
now don't worry about accessing the ui
of the web server for now
we will look more into that in the
upcoming lectures for now let's just
understand the basic commands
we'll now get our hands dirty with the
docker cli so let's take a look at how
to access the practice lab environments
next
[Music]
let me now walk you through the hands-on
lab practice environment
the links to access the labs associated
with this course are available at code
cloud at codecloud.com
p slash docker dash labs this link is
also given in the description of this
video once you're on this page use the
links given there to access the labs
associated to your lecture each lecture
has its own lab so remember to choose
the right lab for your lecture
the labs open up right in your browser
i would recommend to use google chrome
while working with the labs
the interface consists of two parts a
terminal on the left and a quiz portal
on the right
the quiz portal on the right gives you
challenges to solve follow the quiz and
try and answer the questions asked and
complete the tasks given to you
each scenario consists of anywhere from
10 to 20 questions that needs to be
answered within 30 minutes to an hour
at the top you have the question numbers
below that is the remaining time for
your lab below that is the question if
you are not able to solve the challenge
look for hints in the hints section you
may skip a question by hitting the skip
button in the top right corner but
remember that you will not be able to go
back to a previous question once you
have skipped
if the quiz portal gets stuck for some
reason click on the quiz portal tab at
the top to open the quiz portal in a
separate window
the terminal gives you access to a real
system running docker you can run any
docker command here and run your own
containers or applications
you would typically be running commands
to solve the tasks assigned in the quiz
portal
you may play around and experiment with
this environment but
make sure you do that after you've gone
through the quiz so that your work does
not interfere with the tasks provided by
the quiz
so let me walk you through a few
questions
there are two types of questions
each lab scenario starts with a set of
exploratory multiple choice questions
where you're asked to explore and find
information in the given environment and
select the right answer
this is to get you familiarized with a
setup
you are then asked to perform tasks like
run a container stop them delete them
build your own image etc
here the first question asks us to find
the version of docker server engine
running on the host
run the docker version command in the
terminal and identify the right version
then select the appropriate option from
the given choices
another example is the fourth question
where it asks you to run a container
using the redis image
if you are not sure of the command
click on hints and it will show you a
hint
we now run a redis container using the
docker run radius command wait for the
container to run once done click on
check to check your work
you have now successfully completed the
task similarly follow along and complete
all tasks once the lab exercise is
completed
remember to leave a feedback and let us
know how it went a few things to note
these are publicly accessible labs that
anyone can access so if you catch
yourself logged out during a peak hour
please wait for some time and try again
also remember to not store any private
or confidential data on these systems
remember that this environment is for
learning purposes only and is only alive
for an hour
after which the lab is destroyed
so does all your work
but you may start over and access these
labs as many times as you want
until you feel confident i will also
post solutions to these lab quizzes so
if you run into issues you may refer to
those
that's it for now head over to the first
challenge and i will see you on the
other side
[Music]
we will now look at some of the other
docker run commands
at the end of this lecture you will go
through a hands-on quiz where you will
practice working with these commands
we learned that we could use the docker
run redis command to run a container
running a redis service in this case the
latest version of redis which happens to
be
5.0.5 as of today
but what if we want to run another
version of redis like for example an
older version say 4.0
then you specify the version separated
by a colon
this is called a tag
in that case docker pulls an image of
the 4.0 version of redis and runs that
also notice that if you don't specify
any tag as in the first command
docker will consider the default tag to
be latest
latest is a tag associated to the latest
version of that software
which is governed by the authors of that
software
so as a user how do you find information
about these versions and what is the
latest
at dockerhub.com
look up an image and you will find all
the supported tags in its description
each version of the software can have
multiple short and long tags associated
with it as seen here
in this case the version 5.0.5
also has the latest tag on it
let's now look at inputs
i have a simple prompt application that
when run asks for my name
and on entering my name prints a welcome
message
if i were to dockerize this application
and run it as a docker container like
this
it wouldn't wait for the prompt
it just prints whatever the application
is supposed to print on standard out
that is because by default the docker
container does not listen to a standard
input
even though you're attached to its
console it is not able to read any input
from you
it doesn't have a terminal to read
inputs from it runs in a non-interactive
mode
if you would like to provide your input
you must map the standard input of your
host to the docker container using the
dash i parameter the dash i parameter is
for interactive mode and when i input my
name it prints the expected output
but there is something still missing
from this
the prompt
when we run the app
at first it asked us for our name but
when dockerized that prompt is missing
even though it seems to have accepted my
input
that is because the application prompts
on the terminal
and we have not attached to the
container's terminal
for this use the dash t option as well
the dash t stands for a pseudo terminal
so with the combination of dash i and t
we're now attached to the terminal as
well as in an interactive mode
on the container
we will now look at port mapping or port
publishing on containers
let's go back to the example where we
run a simple web application in a docker
container on my docker host
remember the underlying host where
docker is installed is called docker
host or docker engine
when we run a containerized web
application it runs and we are able to
see that the server is running but how
does a user access my application
as you can see my application is
listening on port 5000 so i could access
my application by using port 5000
but what ip do i use to access it from a
web browser
there are two options available one is
to use the ip of the docker container
every docker container gets an ip
assigned by default in this case it is
172.17
but remember that this is an internal ip
and is only accessible within the docker
host
so if you open a browser from within the
docker host you can go to http
colon forward slash forward slash
172.17.0.1
colon 5000 to access the ip address
but since this is an internal ip users
outside of the docker host cannot access
it using this ip
for this we could use the ip of the
docker host which is 192.168.1.5
but for that to work you must have
mapped the port inside the docker
container to a free port on the docker
host
for example if i want the users to
access my application through port 80 on
my docker host i could map port 80 of
localhost to port 5000 on the docker
container using the dash p parameter in
my run command like this
and so the user can access my
application by going to the url
colin slash 192.168.1.5
colon80
and all traffic on port 80 on my docker
host will get router to port 5000 inside
the docker container
this way you can run multiple instances
of your application and map them to
different ports on the docker host
or run instances of different
applications on different ports for
example in this case i am running an
instance of mysql that runs a database
on my host and listens on the default
mysql port which happens to be 3306
or another instance of mysql on another
port
8306
so you can run as many applications like
this and map them to as many ports as
you want
and of course you cannot map to the same
port on the docker host more than once
we will discuss more about port mapping
and networking of containers in the
network lecture later on
let's now look at how data is persisted
in a docker container
for example let's say you were to run a
mysql container
when databases and tables are created
the data files are stored in location
4 lib mysql inside the docker container
remember the docker container has its
own isolated file system and any changes
to any files happen within the container
let's assume you dump a lot of data into
the database
what happens if you were to delete the
mysql container and remove it as soon as
you do that the container along with all
the data inside it gets blown away
meaning all your data is gone
if you would like to persist data you
would want to map a directory outside
the container on the docker host to a
directory inside the container
in this case i create a directory called
opt
data dir and map that to var lib mysql
inside the docker container using the v
option and specifying the directory on
the docker host followed by a colon and
the directory inside the docker
container
this way when docker container runs it
will implicitly mount the external
directory to a folder inside the docker
container this way all your data will
now be stored in the external volume at
slash opt data directory and thus will
remain even if you delete the docker
container
the docker ps command is good enough to
get basic details about containers like
their names and ids but if you would
like to see additional details about a
specific container use the docker
inspect command and provide the
container name or id
it returns all details of a container in
a json format such as the state mounts
configuration data network settings etc
remember to use it when you're required
to find details on a container
and finally how do we see the logs of a
container we run in the background for
example i ran my simple web application
using the dash d parameter and it ran
the container in a detached mode
how do i view the logs which happens to
be the contents written to the standard
out of that container
use the docker logs command and specify
the container id or name like this
well that's it for this lecture head
over to the challenges and practice
working with docker commands
[Music]
let's start with a simple web
application written in python this piece
of code is used to create a web
application that displays a web page
with a background color
if you look closely into the application
code you will see a line that sets the
background color to red
now that works just fine however if you
decide to change the color in the future
you will have to change the application
code it is a best practice to move such
information out of the application code
and into say an environment variable
called app color the next time you run
the application set an environment
variable called app color to a desired
value and the application now has a new
color
once your application gets packaged into
a docker image you will then run it with
the docker run command followed by the
name of the image
however if you wish to pass the
environment variable as we did before
you would now use the docker run
commands dash e option to set an
environment variable within the
container
to deploy multiple containers with
different colors you would run the
docker command multiple times and set a
different value for the environment
variable each time
so how do you find the environment
variable set on a container that's
already running
use the docker inspect command to
inspect the properties of a running
container
under the config section you will find
the list of environment variables set on
the container well that's it for this
lecture on configuring environment
variables in docker
[Music]
hello and welcome to this lecture on
docker images
in this lecture we're going to see how
to create your own image
now before that why would you need to
create your own image
it could either be because you cannot
find a component or a service that you
want to use as part of your application
on docker hub already or you and your
team decided that the application you're
developing will be dockerized for ease
of shipping and deployment
in this case i'm going to containerize
an application a simple web application
that i have built using the python flask
framework
first we need to understand what we are
containerizing or what application we
are creating an image for and how the
application is built
so start by thinking what you might do
if you want to deploy the application
manually
we write down the steps required in the
right order
i'm creating an image for a simple web
application
if i were to set it up manually i would
start with an operating system like
ubuntu then update the source
repositories using the apt command then
install dependencies using the apt
command
then install python dependencies using
the pip command
then copy over the source code of my
application to a location like opt
and then finally run the web server
using the flos command
now that i have the instructions create
a docker file using this here's a quick
overview of the process of creating your
own image
first create a docker file named
dockerfile and write down the
instructions for setting up your
application in it
such as installing dependencies where to
copy the source code from and to and
what the entry point of the application
is etc
once done build your image using the
docker build command and specify the
docker file as input as well as a tag
name for the image
this will create an image locally on
your system
to make it available on the public
docker hub registry
run the docker push command
and specify the name of the image you
just created
in this case
the name of the image is my account
name which is mm shot followed by
the image name which is my custom app
now let's take a closer look at that
docker file
docker file is a text file written in a
specific format that docker can
understand it's in an instruction and
arguments format for example in this
docker file
everything on the left in caps is an
instruction in this case from
run copy and entry point are all
instructions
each of these instruct docker to perform
a specific action while creating the
image
everything on the right is an argument
to those instructions
the first line from ubuntu defines what
the base os should be for this container
every docker image must be based off of
another image
either an os or another image that was
created before based on an os
you can find official releases of all
operating systems on docker hub
it's important to note that all docker
files must start with a from instruction
the run instruction instructs docker to
run a particular command on those base
images
so at this point docker runs the apt-get
update command to fetch the updated
packages and installs required
dependencies on the image
then the copy instruction copies files
from the local system onto the docker
image
in this case the source code of our
application is in the current folder and
i'll be copying it over to the location
opt source code inside the docker image
and finally
entry point allows us to specify a
command that will be run when the image
is run as a container
when docker builds the images it builds
these in a layered architecture each
line of instruction creates a new layer
in the docker image with just the
changes from the previous layer
for example the first layer is a base
ubuntu os followed by
the second instruction that creates a
second layer which installs all the apt
packages and then the third instruction
creates a third layer with the python
packages followed by the fourth layer
that copies the source code over and the
final layer that updates the entry point
of the image
since each layer only stores the changes
from the previous layer it is reflected
in the size as well
if you look at the base ubuntu image it
is around 120 mb in size the apt
packages that i install is around 300 mb
and the remaining layers are small
you could see this information if you
run the docker history command followed
by the image name
when you run the docker build command
you could see the various steps involved
and the result of each task all the
layers built are cast so the layered
architecture helps you restart docker
build from that particular step in case
it fails or if you were to add new steps
in the build process you wouldn't have
to start all over again
all the layers built are cached by
docker so in case a particular step was
to fail for example in this case step 3
failed and you were to fix the issue and
rerun docker build it will reuse the
previous layers from cache and continue
to build the remaining layers
the same is true if you were to add
additional steps in the docker file
this way rebuilding your image is faster
and you don't have to wait for docker to
rebuild the entire image each time
this is helpful especially when you
update source code of your application
as it may change more frequently only
the layers above the updated layers
needs to be rebuilt
we just saw a number of products
containerized
such as databases development tools
operating systems etc
but that's just not it you can
containerize almost all of the
application even simple ones like
browsers or utilities like curl
applications like spotify skype etc
basically you can containerize
everything and going forward i see
that's how everyone is going to run
applications
nobody is going to install anything
anymore going forward instead they're
just going to
run it using docker
and when they don't need it anymore get
rid of it easily without having to clean
up too much
[Music]
in this lecture we will look at commands
arguments and entry points in docker
let's start with a simple scenario say
you were to run a docker container from
an ubuntu image
when you run the docker run ubuntu
command it runs an instance of ubuntu
image and exits immediately
if you were to list the running
containers you wouldn't see the
container running if you list all
containers including those that are
stopped you will see that the new
container you ran is in an exited state
now why is that
unlike virtual machines containers are
not meant to host an operating system
containers are meant to run a specific
task or process
such as to host an instance of a web
server or application server or a
database or simply to carry out some
kind of computation or analysis
once the task is complete the container
exits a container only lives as long as
the process inside it is alive
if the web service inside the container
is stopped or crashes the container
exits so who defines what process is run
within the container if you look at the
docker file for popular docker images
like nginx you will see an instruction
called cmd which stands for command that
defines the program that will be run
within the container when it starts for
the nginx image it is the nginx command
for the mysql image it is the mysqld
command
what we tried to do earlier was to run a
container with a plain ubuntu operating
system
let us look at the docker file for this
image
you will see that it uses bash as the
default command
now bash is not really a process like a
web server or database server it is a
shell that listens for inputs from a
terminal if it cannot find a terminal it
exits
when we ran the ubuntu container earlier
docker created a container from the
ubuntu image and launched the bash
program
by default docker does not attach a
terminal to a container when it is run
and so the bash program does not find
the terminal and so it exits
since the process that was started when
the container was created finished the
container exits as well
so how do you specify a different
command to start the container
one option is to append a command to the
docker run command and that way it
overrides the default command specified
within the image in this case i run the
docker run ubuntu command with the sleep
5 command as the added option
this way when the container starts it
runs the sleep program waits for 5
seconds and then exits but how do you
make that change permanent
say you want the image to always run the
sleep command when it starts
you would then create your own image
from the base ubuntu image and specify a
new command
there are different ways of specifying
the command
either the command simply as is in a
shell form or in a json array format
like this
but remember when you specify in a json
array format the first element in the
array should be the executable in this
case the sleep program
do not specify the command and
parameters together like this the
command and its parameters should be
separate elements in the list
so i now build my new image using the
docker build command
and name it as ubuntu sleeper
i could now simply run the docker ubuntu
sleeper command and get the same results
it always sleeps for 5 seconds and exits
but what if i wish to change the number
of seconds it sleeps
currently it is hard coded to 5 seconds
as we learned before one option is to
run the docker run command with the new
command appended to it in this case
sleep 10 and so the command that will be
run at startup will be sleep10
but it doesn't look very good the name
of the image ubuntu sleeper in itself
implies that the container will sleep so
we shouldn't have to specify the sleep
command again instead we would like it
to be something like this
docker run ubuntu sleeper 10.
we only want to pass in the number of
seconds the container should sleep and
sleep command should be invoked
automatically and that is where the
entry point instruction comes into play
the entry point instruction is like the
command instruction as in you can
specify the program that will be run
when the container starts
and whatever you specify on the command
line in this case 10 will get appended
to the entry point
so the command that will be run when the
container starts is sleep 10.
so that's the difference between the two
in case of the cmd instruction the
command line parameters passed will get
replaced entirely whereas in case of
entry point the command line parameters
will get appended
now in the second case what if i run the
ubuntu sleeper image command without
appending the number of seconds
then the command at startup will be just
sleep and you get the error that the
operand is missing
so how do you configure a default value
for the command if one was not specified
in the command line
that's where you would use both entry
point as well as the command instruction
in this case the command instruction
will be appended to the entry point
instruction
so at startup the command would be sleep
5 if you didn't specify any parameters
in the command line
if you did then that will overwrite the
command instruction and remember for
this to happen you should always specify
the entry point and command instructions
in a json format
finally what if you really really want
to modify the entry point during runtime
say from sleep to an imaginary sleep 2.0
command
well in that case you can override it by
using the entry point option in the
docker run command the final command at
startup would then be sleep 2.0 10.
well that's it for this lecture and i
will see you in the next
[Music]
we now look at networking in docker
when you install docker it creates three
networks automatically bridge
null and host
bridge is the default network a
container gets attached to
if you would like to associate the
container with any other network you
specify the network information using
the network command line parameter like
this
we will now look at each of these
networks
the brit network is a private internal
network created by docker on the host
all containers attach to this network by
default and they get an internal ip
address usually in the range
172.17 series
the containers can access each other
using this internal ip if required
to access any of these containers from
the outside world
map the ports of these containers to
ports on the docker host as we have seen
before
another way to access the containers
externally is to associate the container
to the host network
this takes out any network isolation
between the docker host and the docker
container meaning if you were to run a
web server on port 5000 in a web app
container it is automatically as
accessible on the same port externally
without requiring any port mapping as
the web container uses the host's
network
this would also mean that unlike before
you will now not be able to run multiple
web containers on the same host on the
same port as the ports are now common to
all containers in the host network
with the non-network the containers are
not attached to any network and doesn't
have any access to the external network
or other containers
they run in an isolated network
so we just saw the default bridge
network with the network id 172.17.0.1
so all containers associated to this
default network will be able to
communicate to each other
but what if we wish to isolate the
containers within the docker host for
example the first two web containers on
internal network 172 and the second two
containers on a different internal
network
like 182
by default docker only creates one
internal bridge network
we could create our own internal network
using the command docker network create
and specify the driver which is bridge
in this case and the subnet for that
network followed by the custom isolated
network name
run the docker network ls command to
list all networks
so how do we see the network settings
and the ip address assigned to an
existing container
run the docker inspect command with the
id or name of the container and you will
find a section on network settings
there you can see the type of network
the container is attached to its
internal ip address mac address and
other settings
containers can reach each other using
their names for example in this case i
have a web server and a mysql database
container running on the same node
how can i get my web server to access
the database on the database container
one thing i could do is to use the
internal ip address signed to the mysql
container which in this case is
172.17.0.3
but that is not very ideal because it is
not guaranteed that the container will
get the same ip when the system reboots
the right way to do it is to use the
container name
all containers in a docker host can
resolve each other with the name of the
container docker has a built-in dns
server that helps the containers to
resolve each other using the container
name
note that the built-in dns server always
runs at address 127.0.
so how does docker implement networking
what's the technology behind it like how
are the containers isolated within the
host
docker uses network namespaces that
creates a separate namespace for each
container
it then uses virtual ethernet pairs to
connect containers together
well that's all we can talk about it for
now
more about these are advanced concepts
that we discuss in the advanced course
on docker on code cloud
that's all for now from this lecture on
networking head over to the practice
test and practice working with
networking in docker
i will see you in the next lecture
[Music]
hello and welcome to this lecture and we
are learning advanced docker concepts
in this lecture we are going to talk
about docker storage drivers and file
systems
we're going to see where and how docker
stores data and how it manages file
systems of the containers
let us start with how docker stores data
on the local file system
when you install docker on a system it
creates this folder structure
at
wear lib docker you have multiple
folders under it called aufs containers
image volumes etc
this is where docker stores all its data
by default when i say data i mean files
related to images and containers running
on the docker host
for example all files related to
containers are stored under the
containers folder and the files related
to images are stored under the image
folder
any volumes created by the docker
containers are created under the volumes
folder
well don't worry about that for now we
will come back to that in a bit
for now let's just understand where
docker stores its files and in what
format
so how exactly does docker store the
files of an image and a container
to understand that we need to understand
docker's layered architecture
let's quickly recap something we learned
when docker builds images it builds
these in a layered architecture
each line of instruction in the docker
file creates a new layer in the docker
image with just the changes from the
previous layer for example the first
layer is a base ubuntu operating system
followed by the second instruction that
creates a second layer which installs
all the apt packages and then the third
instruction creates a third layer which
with the python packages
followed by the fourth layer that copies
the source code over and then finally
the fifth layer that updates the entry
point of the image
since each layer only stores the changes
from the previous layer it is reflected
in the size as well
if you look at the base ubuntu image it
is around 120 megabytes in size the apt
packages that i install is around 300 mb
and then the remaining layers are small
to understand the advantages of this
layered architecture let's consider a
second application
this application has a different docker
file but is very similar to our first
application as in it uses the same base
image as ubuntu uses the same python and
flask dependencies but uses a different
source code to create a different
application
and so a different entry point as well
when i run the docker build command to
build a new image for this application
since the first three layers of both the
applications are the same docker is not
going to build the first three layers
instead it reuses the same three layers
it built for the first application from
the cache and only creates the last two
layers with the new sources and the new
entry point
this way docker builds images faster and
efficiently saves disk space
this is also applicable if you were to
update your application code
whenever you update your application
code such as the app.pui in this case
docker simply reuses all the previous
layers from cache and quickly rebuilds
the application image by updating the
latest source code
thus saving us a lot of time during
rebuilds and updates
let's rearrange the layers bottom up so
we can understand it better
at the bottom we have the base ubuntu
layer then the packages
then the dependencies and then the
source code of the application and then
the entry point
all of these layers are created when we
run the docker build command to form the
final docker image
so all of these are the docker image
layers
once the build is complete you cannot
modify the contents of these layers and
so they are read only and you can only
modify them by initiating a new build
when you run a container based off of
this image using the docker run command
docker creates a container based off of
these layers and creates a new writable
layer on top of the image layer
the writable layer is used to store data
created by the container such as log
files written by the applications any
temporary files generated by the
container or just any file modified by
the user on that container
the life of this layer though is only as
long as the container is alive when the
container is destroyed this layer and
all of the changes stored in it are also
destroyed
remember that the same image layer is
shared by all containers created using
this image
if i were to log into the newly created
container and say
create a new file called tem.txt
it will create that file in the
container layer which is read and write
we just said that the files in the image
layer are read-only meaning you cannot
edit anything in those layers
let's take an example of our application
code since we bake our code into the
image the code is part of the image
layer and as such is read-only
after running a container what if i wish
to modify the source code to say test a
change
remember the same image layer may be
shared between multiple containers
created from this image
so does it mean that i cannot modify
this file inside the container
no
i can still modify this file but before
i save the modified file docker
automatically creates a copy of the file
in the read write layer and i will then
be modifying a different version of the
file in the read write layer
all future modifications will be done on
this copy of the file in the rewrite
layer this is called copy on write
mechanism
the image layer being read only just
means that the files in these layers
will not be modified in the image itself
so the image will remain the same all
the time until you rebuild the image
using the docker build command
what happens when we get rid of the
container
all of the data that was stored in the
container layer also gets deleted
the change we made to the app.py and the
new temp file we created will also get
removed
so what if we wish to persist this data
for example if we were working with a
database and we would like to preserve
the data created by the container we
could add a persistent volume to the
container
to do this first create a volume using
the docker volume create command
so when i run the docker volume create
data underscore volume command it
creates a folder called data underscore
volume under the var lib docker
volumes directory
then when i run the docker container
using the docker run command i could
mount this volume inside the docker
container's rewrite layer using the dash
v option like this
so i would do a docker run dash v then
specify my newly created volume name
followed by a colon and the location
inside my container which is the default
location where mysql stores data and
that is var lib mysql
and then the image name mysql
this will create a new container and
mount the data volume we created into
var lib mysql folder inside the
container so all data written by the
database is in fact stored on the volume
created on the docker host
even if the container is destroyed the
data is still active
now what if you didn't run the docker
volume create command to create the
volume before the docker run command
for example if i run the docker run
command to create a new instance of
mysql container with the volume data
underscore volume 2 which i have not
created yet
docker will automatically create a
volume named data underscore volume 2
and mounted to the container you should
be able to see all these volumes if you
list the contents of the var lib docker
volumes folder
this is called volume mounting
as we are mounting a volume created by
docker under the var lib docker volumes
folder
but what if we had our data already at
another location for example let's say
we have some external storage on the
docker host at
forward slash data and we would like to
store database data on that volume and
not in the default var lib docker
volumes folder
in that case we would run a container
using the command docker run dash v
but in this case we will provide the
complete path to the folder we would
like to mount that is forward slash data
forward slash mysql and so it will
create a container and mount the folder
to the container
this is called bind mounting so there
are two types of mounts a volume
mounting and a bind mount
volume mount mounts a volume from the
volumes directory and bind mount mounts
a directory from any location on the
docker host
one final point to note before i let you
go
using the dash v is an old style
the new way is to use dash mount option
the dash dash mount is the preferred way
as it is more verbose so you have to
specify each parameter in a key equals
value format
for example the previous command can be
written with the dash mount option as
this
using the type source and target options
the type in this case is bind the source
is the location on my host and target is
the location on my container
so who is responsible for doing all of
these operations
maintaining the layered architecture
creating a writable layer moving files
across layers to enable copy and write
etc it's the storage drivers so docker
uses storage drivers to enable layered
architecture some of the common storage
drivers are
aufs btrfs zfs device mapper overlay and
overlay 2.
the selection of the storage driver
depends on the underlying os being used
for example with ubuntu the default
storage driver is aufs whereas this
tourist driver is not available on other
operating systems like fedora or centos
in that case device mapper may be a
better option
docker will choose the best storage
driver available automatically based on
the operating system
the different storage drivers also
provide different performance and
stability characteristics
so you may want to choose one that fits
the needs of your application and your
organization
if you would like to read more on any of
these storage drivers
please refer to the links in the
attached documentation
for now that is all from the docker
architecture concepts
see you in the next lecture
[Music]
hello and welcome to this lecture on
docker compose going forward we will be
working with configurations in yaml file
so it is important that you are
comfortable with yaml
let's recap a few things real quick of
course we first learned how to run a
docker container using the docker run
command
if we needed to set up a complex
application running multiple services a
better way to do it is to use docker
compose
with docker compose we could create a
configuration file in yaml format called
dockercompose.yaml and put together the
different services and the options
specific to this
to running them in this file
then we could simply run a docker
compose up command to bring up the
entire application stack
this is easier to implement run and
maintain as all changes are always
stored in the docker compose
configuration file
however this is all only applicable to
running containers on a single docker
host
and for now don't worry about the yaml
file we will take a closer look at the
yaml file in a bit and see how to put it
together
that was a really simple application
that i put together let us look at a
better example
i'm going to use the same sample
application that everyone uses to
demonstrate docker it's a simple yet
comprehensive application developed by
docker to demonstrate the various
features available in running an
application stack on docker so let's
first get familiarized with the
application because we will be working
with the same application in different
sections through the rest of this course
this is a sample voting application
which provides
an interface for a user to vote and
another interface to show the results
the application consists of various
components such as the voting app which
is a web application developed in python
to provide the user with an interface to
choose between two options
a cat and a dog
when you make a selection the vote is
stored in redis
for those of you who are new to redis
redis in this case serves as a database
in memory
this vote is then processed by the
worker which is an application written
in dot net the worker application takes
the new vote and updates the persistent
database which is a postgres sql in our
case
the postgres sql simply has a table with
the number of votes for each category
cats and docs
in this case it increments the number of
votes for cats as our vote was for cats
finally the result of the vote is
displayed in a web interface which is
another web application developed in
node.js
this resulting application reads the
count of votes from the postgres sql
database and displays it to the user
so that is the architecture and data
flow of this simple
voting application stack
as you can see this sample application
is built with a combination of different
services
different development tools and multiple
different development platforms such as
python
nodejs.net etc
this sample application will be used to
showcase how easy it is to set up an
entire application stack consisting of
diverse components in docker
let us keep aside docker swarm services
and stacks for a minute and see how we
can put together this application stack
on a single docker engine using
first docker run commands and then
docker compose
let us assume that all images of
applications are already built and are
available on docker repository
let us start with the data layer
first we run the docker run command to
start an instance of redis by running
the docker run redis command
we will add the d parameter to run this
container in the background and we will
also name the container redis
now naming the containers is important
why is that important hold that thought
we will come to that in a bit
next we will deploy the postgres sql
database by running the docker run
postgres command
this time too we will add the d option
to run this in the background and name
this container db for database
next we will start with the application
services
we will deploy a front-end app for
voting interface by running an instance
of voting app image
run the docker run command and name the
instance vote
since this is a web server it has a web
ui instance running on port 80. we will
publish that port to 5000 on the host
system so we can access it from a
browser
next we will deploy the result a web
application that shows the results to
the user
for this we deploy a container using the
result-app image and publish port 80 to
port 5001 on the host
this way we can access the web ui of the
resulting app on a browser
finally we deploy the worker by running
an instance of the worker image
okay
now this is all good and we can see that
all the instances are running on the
host
but there is some problem
it just does not seem to work
the problem is that we have successfully
run all the different containers but we
haven't actually linked them together
as in we haven't told the voting web
application to use this particular redis
instance
there could be multiple redis instances
running
we haven't told the worker and the
resulting app to use this particular
postgresql database that we ran
so how do we do that
that is where we use links
link is a command line option which can
be used to link two containers together
for example
the voting app web service is dependent
on the redis service
when the web server starts as you can
see in this piece of code on the web
server it looks for a redis service
running on host redis
but the voting app container cannot
resolve a host by the name redis
to make the voting app aware of the
redis service we add a link option while
running the voting app container to link
it to the red disk container
adding a dash dash link option to the
docker run command and specifying the
name of the redis container which is
which in this case is redis followed by
a colon and the name of the host that
the voting app is looking for which is
also redis in this case
remember that this is why we named the
container when we ran it the first time
so we could use its name while creating
a link
what this is in fact doing is it creates
an entry into the etc hosts file on the
voting app container adding an entry
with the host named rebis with the
internal ip of the red disk container
similarly we add a link for the result
app to communicate with the database by
adding a link option to refer
the database by the name db
as you can see in this source code of
the application it makes an attempt to
connect to a postgres database on host
db
finally the worker application requires
access to both the redis as well as the
postgres database so we add two links to
the worker application one link to link
the redis and the other link to link
postgres database
note that using links this way is
deprecated and the support may be
removed in
future in docker
this is because as we will see in some
time
advanced and newer concepts in docker
swarm and networking supports better
ways of achieving what we just did here
with links
but i wanted to mention it anyway so you
learn the concept from the very basics
once we have the docker run commands
tested and ready it is easy to generate
a docker compose file from it we start
by creating a dictionary of container
names we will use the same name we used
in the docker run commands so we take
all the names and create a key with each
of them
then under each item we specify which
image to use
the key is the image and the value
is the name of the image to use
next inspect the commands and see what
are the other options used
we published ports so let's move those
ports under the respective containers
so we create a property called ports and
list all the ports that you would like
to publish under that
finally we are left with links
so whichever container requires a link
create a property under it called links
and provide an array of links such as
redis or tb
note that you could also specify the
name of the link this way without the
semicolon and and the target target name
and it will create a link
with the same name as the target name
specifying the db colon db is similar to
simply specifying db
we will assume the same value to create
a link
now that we're all done with our docker
compose file bringing up the stack is
really simple run the docker compose up
command to bring up the entire
application stack
when we looked at the example of the
sample voting application we assumed
that all images are already built
out of the five different components two
of them redis and postgres images we
know are already available on docker hub
they are official images from redis and
postgres
but the remaining three are our own
application
it is not necessary that they are
already built and available in a docker
registry
if we would like to instruct docker
compose to run a docker build instead of
trying to pull an image we could replace
the image line with a build line and
specify the location of a directory
which contains the application code and
a docker file with instructions to build
the docker image
in this example
for the voting app i have all the
application code in a folder named vote
which contains all application code
and a docker file
this time when you run the docker
compose up command it will first build
the images give a temporary name for it
and then use those images to run
containers using the options you
specified before
similarly use build
option to build the two other services
from the respective folders
we will now look at different versions
of docker compose file
this is important because you might see
docker compose files in different
formats at different places and wonder
why some look different
docker compose evolved over time and now
supports a lot more options than it did
in the beginning
for example
this is the trimmed down version of the
docker compose file we used earlier
this is in fact the original version of
docker compose file known as version one
this had a number of limitations for
example if you wanted to deploy
containers on a different network other
than the default bridge network there
was no way of specifying that in this
version of the file
also say you have a dependency or
startup order of some kind for example
your database container must come up
first and only then
should the voting application be started
there was no way you could specify that
in the version 1
of the docker compose file
support for these came in version 2.
with version 2
and up the format of the file also
changed a little bit
you no longer specify your stack
information directly as you did before
it is all encapsulated in a services
section so create a property called
services in the root of the file and
then move all the services underneath
that
you will still use the same docker
compose up command to bring up your
application stack
but how does docker compose know what
version of the file you're using
you're free to use version 1 or version
2 depending on your needs so how does
the docker compose
know what format you are using
for version 2 and up you must specify
the version of docker compose file you
are intending to use by specifying the
version at the top of the file
in this case version colon 2.
another difference is
with networking in version 1 docker
compose attaches all the containers it
runs to the default
bridged network
and then use links to enable
communication between the containers as
we did before
with version 2 docker compose
automatically creates a dedicated
bridged network for this application and
then attaches all containers to that new
network
all containers are then able to
communicate to each other using each
other's service name
so you basically don't need to use links
in version 2 of docker compose
you can simply get rid of all the links
you mentioned in version 1 when you
convert a file from version 1 to version
2.
and finally
version 2 also introduces a depends on
feature
if you wish to specify a startup order
for instance say the voting web
application is dependent on the redis
service so you need to ensure that redis
container is started first and only then
the voting web application must be
started
we could add a depends on property to
the voting application and indicate that
it is dependent on redis
then comes version 3 which is the latest
as of today
version 3 is similar to version 2 in in
the structure meaning it has a version
specification at the top and a services
section under which you put all your
services just like in version 2.
make sure to specify the version number
as 3 at the top
version 3 comes with support for docker
swamp which we will see later on
there are some options that were removed
and added to see details on those you
could refer to the documentation section
using the link in the reference page
following this lecture
we will see version 3 in much detail
later when we discuss about docker
stacks
let us talk about networks in docker
compose
getting back to our application
so far we have been just deploying all
containers on the default bridged
network
let us say we modify the architecture a
little bit to contain the traffic from
the different sources for example we
would like to separate the
user-generated traffic from the
application's internal traffic so we
create a front-end network dedicated for
traffic from users and a backend network
dedicated for traffic within the
application
we then connect the user-facing
applications which are the voting app
and the result app to the front-end
network
and all the components to an internal
back-end network
so back in our docker compose file
note that i have actually stripped out
the port section for simplicity's sake
they're still there but they're just not
shown here
the first thing we need to do if we were
to use networks is to define the
networks we are going to use in our case
we have two networks front-end and
back-end so create a new property called
networks at the root level adjacent to
the services in the docker compose file
and add a map of networks we are
planning to use
then under each service create a
networks property and provide a list of
networks that service must be attached
to
in case of redis and db
it's only the backend network
in case of the front-end applications
such as
the voting app and the result app
they're required to be attached to both
a front-end and back-end network
you must also add a section for worker
container to be added to the backend
network
i have just omitted that in this slide
due to space constraints
now that you have seen docker compose
files head over to the coding exercises
and practice developing some docker
compose files
that's it for this lecture
and i will see you in the next lecture
[Music]
we will now look at docker registry
so what is a registry
if the containers were the rain then
they would rain from the docker registry
which are the clouds
that's where docker images are stored
it's a central repository of all docker
images
let's look at a simple nginx container
we run the docker run nginx command to
run an instance of the nginx image
let's take a closer look at that image
name
now the name is nginx but what is this
image and where is this image pulled
from
this name follows docker's image naming
convention
nginx here is the image or the
repository name
when you say nginx it's actually
nginx slash nginx the first part stands
for the user or account name so if you
don't provide
an account or a repository name it
assumes that it is the same as the given
name which in this case is nginx
the usernames is usually your dockerhub
account name or if it is an organization
then it's the name of the organization
if you were to create your own account
and create your own repositories or
images under it then you would use a
similar pattern
now where are these images stored and
pulled from
since we have not specified the location
where these images are to be pulled from
it is assumed to be on docker's default
registry docker hub the dns name for
which is docker.io
the registry is where all the images are
stored whenever you create a new image
or update an existing image you push it
to the registry and every time anyone
deploys this application it is pulled
from that registry there are many other
popular registries as well for example
google's registry is at gcr.io where a
lot of kubernetes related images are
stored like the ones used for performing
end-to-end tests on the cluster
these are all publicly accessible images
that anyone can download and access
when you have applications built in
house that shouldn't be made available
to the public
hosting an internal private registry may
be a good solution
many cloud service providers such as aws
azure or gcp provide a private registry
by default when you open an account with
them
on any of these solutions be it docker
hub or google registry or your internal
private registry you may choose to make
a repository private so that it can only
be accessed using a set of credentials
from docker's perspective to run a
container using an image from a private
registry you first log into your private
registry using the docker login command
input your credentials
once successful run the application
using private registry as part of the
image name like this
now if you did not log into the private
registry it will come back saying that
the image cannot be found
so remember to always log in before
pulling or pushing to a private registry
we said that cloud providers like aws or
gcp provide a private registry when you
create an account with them but what if
you're running your application on
premise and don't have a private
registry how do you deploy your own
private registry within your
organization
the docker registry is itself another
application and of course is available
as a docker image
the name of the image is registry and it
exposes the api on port 5000
now that you have your custom registry
running at port 5000 on this docker host
how do you push your own image to it
use the docker image tag command to tag
the image with a private registry url in
it in this case since it's running on
the same docker host i can use localhost
semicolon 5000 followed by the image
name
i can then push my image to my local
private registry using the command
docker push and the new image name with
the docker registry information in it
from there on i can pull my image from
anywhere within this network using
either localhost if you're on the same
host or the ip or domain name of my
docker host if i'm accessing from
another host in my
environment well that's it for this
lecture head over to the practice test
and practice working with private doctor
registries
[Music]
welcome to this lecture on docker engine
in this lecture we will take a deeper
look at docker's architecture how it
actually runs applications in isolated
containers and how it works under the
hoods
docker engine as we have learned before
is simply referred to a host with docker
installed on it when you install docker
on a linux host you're actually
installing three different components
the docker daemon the rest api server
and the docker cli
the docker daemon is a background
process that manages docker objects such
as the images containers volumes and
networks
the docker rest api server is the api
interface that programs can use to talk
to the daemon and provide instructions
you could create your own tools using
this rest api
and the docker cli is nothing but the
command line interface that we've been
using until now to perform actions such
as running a container stopping
containers destroying images etc
it uses the rest api to interact with
the docker daemon
something to note here is that the
docker cli need not necessarily be on
the same host it could be on another
system like a laptop and can still work
with a remote docker engine
simply use the dash h option on the
docker command and specify the remote
docker engine address and the port as
shown here
for example to run a container based on
nginx on a remote docker host run the
command docker h equals
10.123.2.1 colon 2375
run nginx
now let's try and understand how exactly
are applications containerized in docker
how does it work under the hoods docker
uses namespaces to isolate workspace
process ids network inter-process
communication
mounts and unix time sharing systems are
created in their own namespace thereby
providing isolation between containers
let's take a look at one of the
namespace isolation technique process id
namespaces
whenever a linux system boots up it
starts with just one process with a
process id of one
this is the root process and kicks off
all the other processes in the system
by the time the system boots up
completely we have a handful of
processors running
this can be seen by running the ps
command to list all the running
processes
the process ids are unique and two
processors cannot have the same process
id
now if we were to create a container
which is basically like a child system
within the current system
the child system needs to think that it
is an independent system on its own and
it has its own set of processes
originating from a root process with a
process id of one
but we know that there is no hard
isolation between the containers and the
underlying host so the processes running
inside the container are in fact
processors running on the underlying
host and so two processes cannot have
the same process id of one
this is where namespaces come into play
with process id namespaces each process
can have multiple process ids associated
with it for example when the processes
start in the container it's actually
just another set of processes on the
base linux system and it gets the next
available process id
in this case 5 and 6. however they also
get another process id starting with
pid1 in the container namespace which is
only visible inside the container so the
container thinks that it has its own
root process tree and so it is an
independent system
so how does that relate to an actual
system how do you see this on a host
let's say i were to run an nginx server
as a container we know that the nginx
container runs an nginx service
if we were to list all the services
inside the docker container we see that
the nginx service running with a process
id of one
this is the process id of the service
inside of the container namespace
if we list the services on the docker
host we will see the same service but
with a different process id
that indicates that all processes are in
fact running on the same host but
separated into their own containers
using namespaces
so we learned that the underlying docker
host as well as the containers shared
the same system resources such as cpu
and memory
how much of the resources are dedicated
to the host and the containers and how
does docker manage and share the
resources between the containers
by default there is no restriction as to
how much of a resource a container can
use
and hence a container may end up
utilizing all of the resources on the
underlying host
but there is a way to restrict the
amount of cpu or memory a container can
use
docker uses c groups or control groups
to restrict the amount of hardware
resources allocated to each container
this can be done by providing the dash
dash cpus option to the docker run
command providing a value of 0.5 will
ensure that the container does not take
up more than 50 percent of the host cpu
at any given time
the same goes with memory setting a
value of 100m to the dash dash memory
option
limits the amount of memory the
container can use to a hundred megabytes
if you are interested in reading more on
this topic refer to the links i posted
in the reference page
that's it for now on docker engine
in the next lecture we talk about other
advanced topics on docker storage and
file systems
see you in the next leg
[Music]
earlier in this course we learned that
containers share the underlying os
kernel and as a result we cannot have a
windows container running on linux host
or vice versa we need to keep this in
mind while going through this lecture as
it's very important concept and most
beginners tend to have an issue with it
so what are the options available for
docker on windows
there are two options available the
first one is docker on windows using
docker toolbox and the second one is the
docker desktop for windows option we
will look at each of these now
let's take a look at the first option
docker toolbox
this was the original support for docker
on windows
imagine that you have a windows laptop
and no access to any linux system
whatsoever but you would like to try
docker
you don't have access to a linux system
in the lab or in the cloud
what would you do
what i did was to install a
virtualization software on my windows
system like oracle virtualbox or vmware
workstation and deploy a linux vm on it
such as ubuntu or debian
then install docker on the linux vm and
then play around with it
this is what the first option
really does it doesn't really have
anything much to do with windows you
cannot create windows based docker
images
or run windows based docker containers
you obviously cannot run linux container
directly on windows either you're just
working with docker on a linux virtual
machine on a windows host
docker however provides us with a set of
tools to make this easy which is called
as the docker toolbox
the docker toolbox contains a set of
tools like oracle virtualbox docker
engine docker machine docker compose and
a user interface called kitematic
this will help you get started by simply
downloading and running the docker
toolbox executable it will install
virtualbox deploy a lightweight vm
called boot to docker which has docker
running in it already so that you are
all set to start with docker easily and
with within a short period of time
now what about requirements you must
ensure that your operating system is
64-bit windows 7 or higher and that the
virtualization is enabled on the system
now remember
docker toolbox is legacy solution for
older windows systems that do not meet
requirements for the newer docker for
windows option
the second option is the newer
option called docker desktop for windows
in the previous option we saw that we
had oracle virtualbox installed on
windows and then a linux system and then
docker on that linux system
now with docker for windows we take out
oracle virtualbox and use the native
virtualization technology available with
windows called microsoft hyper wii
during the installation process for
docker for windows it will still
automatically create a linux system
underneath but this time it is created
on the microsoft hyper-v instead of
oracle virtualbox and have docker
running on that system
because of this dependency on hyper-v
this option is only supported for
windows 10 enterprise or professional
edition and on windows server 2016
because both these operating systems
come with hyper-v support by default
now here's the most important point
so far whatever we have been discussing
with docker's support for windows it is
strictly for linux containers linux
applications packaged into linux docker
images we're not talking about windows
applications or windows images or
windows containers
both the options we just discussed will
help you run a linux container on a
windows host
with windows server 2016
microsoft announced support for windows
containers for the first time you can
now package applications windows
applications into windows docker
containers and run them on windows
docker host using docker desktop for
windows
when you install docker desktop for
windows the default option is to work
with linux containers but if you would
like to run windows containers then you
must explicitly configure docker for
windows to switch to using windows
containers
in early 2016 microsoft announced
windows containers now you could create
windows based images and run windows
containers on a windows server just like
how you would
run linux containers on a linux system
now you can create windows images
containerize your applications and share
them through the docker store as well
unlike in linux there are two types of
containers in windows
the first one is a windows server
container which works exactly like linux
containers where the os kernel is shared
with the underlying operating system
to allow better security boundary
between containers and to allow kernels
with different versions and
configurations to coexist
the second option was introduced known
as the hyper-v isolation with hyper-v
isolation each container is run within a
highly optimized virtual machine
guaranteeing complete kernel isolation
between the containers and the
underlying host
now while in the linux world you had a
number of
base images for linux systems such as
ubuntu debian fedora alpine etc if you
remember that that is what you specify
at the beginning of the docker file in
the windows world we have two options
the windows server core
and nano server a nano server is a
headless deployment option for windows
server which runs at a fraction of size
of the full operating system you can
think of this like the alpine image in
linux
the windows server core though is not as
lightweight as you might expect it to be
finally windows containers are supported
on windows server 2016 nano server and
windows 10 professional and enterprise
edition
remember on windows 10 professional and
enterprise edition only supports hyper-v
isolated containers
meaning as we just discussed every
container deployed is deployed on a
highly optimized virtual machine
well that's it about
docker on windows now before i finish i
want to point out one important fact
we saw two ways of running a docker
container using virtualbox or hyperweave
but remember virtualbox and hyperweight
cannot coexist on the same windows host
so if you started off with docker
toolbox with virtualbox and if you plan
to migrate to hyper-v remember you
cannot have both solutions at the same
time there is a migration guide
available on docker documentation page
on how to migrate from virtualbox to
hyperweight
that's it for now thank you and i will
see you in the next lecture
[Music]
we now look at docker on mac
docker on mac is similar to docker on
windows there are two options to get
started docker and mac using docker
toolbox or docker desktop for mac option
let's look at the first option docker
toolbox
this was the original support for docker
on mac
it is docker on a linux vm created using
virtualbox on mac
as with windows it has nothing to do
with mac applications or mac based
images or mac containers it purely runs
linux containers on a mac os
docker toolbox contains a set of tools
like oracle virtualbox docker engine
docker machine docker compose and a user
interface called kitematic when you
download and install the docker toolbox
executable it installs virtualbox
deploys lightweight vm called boot to
docker which has docker running in it
already
this requires mac os 10.8 or newer
the second option is the newer option
called docker desktop for mac
with docker desktop for mac we take out
oracle virtualbox and use hyperkit
virtualization technology
during the installation process for
docker for mac it will still
automatically create a linux system
underneath but this time it is created
on hyperkit instead of oracle virtualbox
and have docker running on that system
this requires mac os sierra 10.12 or
newer and my and the mac hardware must
be 2010 or newer model
finally remember that all of this is to
be able to run the linux container on
mac as of this recording there are no
mac based images or containers
well that's it with docker on mac for
now
[Music]
we will now try to understand what
container orchestration is
so far in this course we have seen that
with docker you can run a single
instance of the application with a
simple docker run command in this case
to run a node.js based application
you're on the docker run node.js command
but that's just one instance of your
application on one docker host what
happens when the number of users
increase and that instance is no longer
able to handle the load you deploy
additional instance of your application
by running the docker run command
multiple times
so that's something you have to do
yourself
you have to keep a close watch on the
load and performance of your application
and deploy additional instances yourself
and not just that you have to keep a
close watch on the health of these
applications
and if a container was to fail you
should be able to detect that and run
the docker run command again to deploy
another instance of that application
what about the health of the docker host
itself what if the host crashes and is
inaccessible
the containers hosted on that host
become inaccessible too
so what do you do in order to solve
these issues you will need a dedicated
engineer who can sit and monitor the
state performance and health of the
containers and take necessary actions to
remediate the situation but when you
have large applications deployed with
tens of thousands of containers that's
that's not a practical approach so
you can build your own scripts and and
that will help you
tackle these issues to some extent
container orchestration
is just a solution for that it is a
solution that consists of a set of tools
and scripts that can help host
containers in a production environment
typically a container orchestration
solution consists of multiple docker
hosts that can host containers
that way even if one fails the
application is still accessible through
the others
a container orchestration solution
easily allows you to deploy hundreds or
thousands of instances of your
application with a single command
this is a command used for docker swarm
we will look at the command itself in a
bit
some orchestration solutions can help
you automatically scale up the number of
instances when users increase and scale
down the number of instances when the
demand decreases
some solutions can even help you in
automatically adding additional hosts to
support the user load and not just
clustering and scaling the container
orchestration solutions also provide
support for advanced networking between
these containers across different hosts
as well as load balancing user requests
across different house they also provide
support for sharing storage between the
hosts as well as support for
configuration management and security
within the cluster
there are multiple container
orchestration solutions available today
docker has docker swamp
kubernetes from google and mesos from
apache
while docker swarm is really easy to set
up and get started it lacks some of the
advanced auto scaling features required
for complex production-grade
applications
mesos on the other hand is quite
difficult to set up and get started
but supports many advanced features
kubernetes arguably the most popular of
it all is a bit difficult to set up and
get started but provides a lot of
options to customize deployments and has
support for many different vendors
kubernetes is now supported on all
public cloud service providers like gcp
azure and aws and the kubernetes project
is one of the top ranked projects on
github
in the upcoming lectures we will take a
quick look at docker swamp and
kubernetes
[Music]
we will now get a quick introduction to
docker swarm
docker swamp has a lot of concepts to
cover and requires its own course
but we will try to take a quick look at
some of the basic details so you can get
a brief idea on what it is
with docker swamp you could now combine
multiple docker machines together into a
single cluster docker swarm will take
care of distributing your services or
your application instances
into separate hosts for high
availability and for load balancing
across different systems and hardware
to set up a docker swamp you must first
have hosts or multiple hosts with docker
installed on them then you must
designate one host to be the manager or
the master or the swamp manager as it is
called and others as slaves or workers
once you're done with that run the
docker swamp init command on the swamp
manager and that will initialize the
swamp manager the output will also
provide the command to be run on the
workers so copy the command and run it
on the worker notes to join the manager
after joining the swamp the workers are
also referred to as nodes and you're now
ready to create services and deploy them
on the swamp cluster
so let's get into some more details as
you already know to run an instance of
my web server i run the docker run
command and specify the name of the
image i wish to run this creates a new
container instance of my application and
serves my web server
now that we have learned how to create a
swamp cluster how do i utilize my
cluster to run multiple instances of my
web server now one way to do this would
be to run the docker run command on each
worker node but that's not ideal as i
might have to log into each node and run
this command
and there could be hundreds of nodes
i will have to set up load balancing
myself i'll have to monitor the state of
each instance myself and if instances
were to fail i'll have to restart them
myself so it's going to be an impossible
task
that is where docker swamp orchestration
comes in docker swamp orchestrator does
all of this for us so far we've only set
up the swamp cluster but we haven't seen
orchestration in action the key
component of swamp orchestration is the
docker as service docker services are
one or more instances of a single
application or service that runs across
the saw the nodes in the swamp cluster
for example in this case i could create
a docker service to run multiple
instances of my web server application
across worker nodes in my swamp cluster
for this i run the docker service create
command on the manager node and specify
my image name there
which is my web server in this case and
use the option replicas to specify the
number of instances of my web server i
would like to run across the cluster
since i specified three replicas and i
get
three instances of my web server
distributed across the different worker
nodes
remember the docker service command must
be run on the manager node and not on
the worker node the docker service
create command is similar to the docker
run command in terms of the options
passed such as the e environment
variable the dash p for publishing ports
the network option to attach container
to a network etc
well that's a high level introduction to
docker swamp there is a lot more to know
such as configuring multiple managers
overlay networks etc as i mentioned it
requires its own separate course
well that's it for now
in the next lecture we will look at
kubernetes at a high level
[Music]
we will now get a brief introduction to
basic kubernetes concepts again
kubernetes requires its own course well
a few courses at least five
but we will try to get a brief
introduction to it here
with docker you were able to run a
single instance of an application using
the docker cli by running the docker run
command which is great running an
application has never been so easy
before
with kubernetes using the kubernetes cli
known as cubecontrol you can run a
thousand instance of the same
application with a single command
kubernetes can scale it up to 2000 with
another command kubernetes can be even
configured to do this automatically so
that instances and the infrastructure
itself can scale up and down based on
user load
kubernetes can upgrade these 2000
instances of the application in a
rolling upgrade fashion one at a time
with a single command if something goes
wrong it can help you roll back these
images with a single command
kubernetes can help you test new
features of your application
by only upgrading a percentage of these
instances through a b testing methods
the kubernetes open architecture
provides support for many many different
network and storage vendors any network
or storage brand that you can think of
has a plugin for kubernetes
kubernetes supports a variety of
authentication and authorization
mechanisms all major cloud service
providers have native support for
kubernetes
so what's the relation between docker
and kubernetes well kubernetes uses
docker hosts to host applications in the
form of docker containers
well it need not be docker all the time
kubernetes supports alternatives to
dockers as well such as rocket or cryo
let's take a quick look at the
kubernetes architecture
a kubernetes cluster consists of a set
of nodes let us start with nodes a node
is a machine physical or virtual on
which a kubernetes the kubernetes
software set of tools are installed a
node is a worker machine and that is
where containers will be launched by
kubernetes
but what if the node on which the
application is running fails well
obviously our application goes down so
you need to have more than one nodes a
cluster is a set of nodes grouped
together this way even if one node fails
you have your application still
accessible from the other nodes
now we have a cluster but who is
responsible for managing this cluster
where is the information about the
members of the cluster stored how are
the nodes monitored
when a node fails how do you move the
workload of the field node to another
worker node
that's where the master comes in the
master is a node with the kubernetes
control plane components installed
the master watches over the notes in the
cluster and is responsible for the
actual orchestration of containers on
the worker notes
when you install kubernetes on a system
you're actually installing the following
components an api server an hcd server a
cubelet service a container runtime
engine like docker and a bunch of
controllers and the scheduler
the api server acts as the front end for
kubernetes the user's management devices
command line interfaces all talk to the
api server to interact with the
kubernetes cluster
next is the fcd a key value store the
lcd is a distributed reliable key value
store used by kubernetes to store all
data used to manage the cluster think of
it this way when you have multiple nodes
and multiple masters in your cluster xcd
stores all that information on all the
nodes in the cluster in a distributed
manner scd is responsible for
implementing
logs within the cluster to ensure there
are no conflicts between the masters
the scheduler is responsible for
distributing work or containers across
multiple nodes it looks for newly
created containers and assigns them to
nodes
the controllers are the brain behind
orchestration they're responsible for
noticing and responding when nodes
containers or end
goes down
the controllers makes decisions to bring
up new containers in such cases the
container runtime is the underlying
software that is used to run containers
in our case it happens to be docker
and finally cubelet is the agent that
runs on each node in the cluster the
agent is responsible for making sure
that the containers are running on the
nodes as expected and finally we also
need to learn a little bit about one of
the command line utilities known as the
cube command line tool or the cube
control tool or cube cuddle as it is
also called
the cube control tool is the kubernetes
cli which is used to deploy and manage
applications on a kubernetes cluster to
get cluster related information to get
the status of the nodes in the cluster
and many other things
the cube control run command is used to
deploy an application on the cluster the
cube control cluster info command is
used to view information about the
cluster and the cube control get nodes
command is used to list all the nodes
part of the cluster
so to run hundreds of instances of your
application across hundreds of nodes all
i need is a single kubernetes command
like this
well that's all we have for now a quick
introduction to kubernetes and this
architecture we currently have three
courses on code cloud on kubernetes that
will take you from the absolute beginner
to a certified expert so have a look at
it when you get a chance
[Music]
so we're at the end of this beginner's
course to docker i hope you had a great
learning experience if so please leave a
comment below
if you like my way of teaching you will
love my other courses hosted on my site
at code cloud we have courses for docker
swarm kubernetes advanced courses on
kubernetes certifications as well as
openshift we have courses for automation
tools like ansible chef and puppet and
many more on the way
visit code cloud at www.codecloud.com
well thank you so much for your time and
until next time
bye
[Music]